victoria saha joining us now from north
las vegas and victoria neighbors telling
you they've worried about something like
this happening
yeah brian and denise but first we are
just learning new information we are
finding out the name of one of the
victims that was involved in the plane
crash yesterday family says that
47-year-old zach rainey was in the plane
with his instructor when it crashed but
today i spoke with several residents who
live nearby they're telling me what they
see on a daily coming in and out of this
airport and they tell me after
yesterday's crash they're very concerned
the north las vegas airport is home to
many private planes and aviation
enthusiasts and with many flight schools
surrounding it it makes for a busy
airport for inbound and outbound flights
all day long residents like dan dino
garcia living nearby sees planes flying
very close to his house and plane
crashes just like the one that occurred
sunday are a constant worry for him what
do you always think when you see a plane
so close to your house well hopefully
don't crash here they come almost
directly over my apartment maybe a
hundred feet hundred yards we have
uncovered the registration for two
planes involved in the sunday afternoon
crash according to the aviation safety
network the cessna skyhawk is registered
to binner enterprises llc which is
registered in henderson the piper plane
coming from idaho is owned by gold arrow
aviation which is registered to a las
vegas and a florida address
every shot to both companies but if
still not heard back again this crash
killed four people reporting near north
las vegas victoria saha live local now